looking for a thrilling movie night but
stuck on what to watch don't worry
netflix is jam-packed with great
thrillers that'll send a chill up your
spine from criminally overlooked heist
flicks to gritty hard-boiled Revenge
tales here are all the best thrillers on
Netflix that nobody seems to be talking
about small crimes directed by Evan Katz
2017 small crimes takes Jamie Lannister
out of Westeros and sticks him in the
middle of small-town America played by
Nikolaj coster-waldau Joe Denton is a
corrupt cop recently released from
prison after carving up the local DA now
that he's a free man this alcoholic
narcissist is trapped in limbo with
everyone giving him the evil eye his mom
is pressuring him to clean up his life
his wife and kids won't talk to him and
random strangers are trying to bash his
head in
we're still a sleazy police lieutenant
wants Joe to take out a dying gangster
to make sure the mobster doesn't squeal
on all the dirty cops in town but really
this is a movie that defies plot
description as small crimes delves into
some twisty plot lines involving
prostitution drunken soldiers and a
deranged gangster with his own personal
torture dungeon coster-waldau is at his
best here and this complicated plot
unfolds with a gut punch of a final
showdown one that will leave you looking
at the deadbeat protagonists in a
completely different light despite all
the twists and turns small crimes is
ultimately a movie about forgiveness and
whether or not we deserve it The Crying
Game
directed by Neil Jordan The Crying Game
was hailed as one of the best films of
1992 but in subsequent years it's been
overshadowed by some of its cinematic
cousins that's a shame because this
moody thriller has it all from
heart-wrenching romance to hair pulling
tension the film follows an IRA
terrorist named Fergus who befriends a
British soldier played by Forest
Whitaker talk about you people what do
you know about my people unfortunately
for their friendship Fergus is supposed
to shoot the poor trooper Whitaker's
character asks Fergus to check on his
girlfriend after he's gone eventually
Fergus leaves the IRA travels to London
and meets dill the soldiers girlfriend
he quickly falls for her but that hole I
shot your boyfriend secret is always
looming in the background it doesn't
help matters that the IRA is busy
looking for Fergus wanting to bring him
back to the fold honestly there's a lot
more going on in this film than we can
possibly say so if you want to
experience the end
higher emotional experience than you'll
definitely want to visit Netflix and try
playing The Crying Game
cartel land produced by Kathryn Bigelow
and directed by Matthew Hyneman cartel
land is a visceral thriller that feels a
lot like The Hurt Locker or zero dark
thirty the only difference is that
cartel land is a documentary there are
no actors no script just real-life
people armed to the teeth
this white-knuckle 2015 thriller follows
two vigilante groups on opposite sides
of the border as they battle incredibly
violent Mexican cartels we witness
actual gunfights real-life torture and
one of the most harrowing car rides in
cinematic history the movie also takes a
nuanced look at the issue showing how
vigilantes are fighting for their lives
against gangs on the other hand these
vigilante groups have a tendency to go
overboard and over on the American side
there's some horrible racism fueling
their efforts to hunt down people who
come across the border why would you put
two races in the same nation and expect
them to get along cartel land flanges
viewers right into the blood and guts
reality of the drug war and even though
it's a documentary it's as thrilling as
any fictional film you'll ever see the
gift written and directed by Joel
Edgerton the gift is a creepy little
suspense flick from 2015 that will make
you think twice when an old friend calls
and wants to catch up the plot follows
Simon and Robyn Callum a seemingly happy
couple played by Jason Bateman and
Rebecca Hall they've gone through some
trauma but now they're looking to start
over in a new city in a new house and
with new lives unfortunately for the
couple Simon runs into an old friend
from school
a man named Gordo Gordo the weirdo at
first Gordo seems a little too eager to
please but as strange gifts show up on
the Callum's porch and tensions escalate
it looks like Gordo might have more on
his mind than reminiscing about the good
old days that's just scratching the
surface of the story and without saying
much more about the plot the gift is a
tense and nasty little movie with
unsettling performances from its three
brilliant leads not to mention an ending
that will likely leave you genuinely
upset a patch of fog if you've seen
Boardwalk Empire than you know Steven
Graham can be one intimidating dude and
he brings that same manic energy to a
patch of fog in this atmosphere at 2015
Game of Thrones Conliffe hill plays a
famous author named Sandy Duff who's
living off the proceeds of a 20 year old
book when he's not giving lectures or
appearing on TV he spends his spare time
shoplifting which majorly backfires when
he's caught by a psycho security guard
named Robert played by Graham however
Robert doesn't want to turn sandy over
to the police
Robert just wants to be friends
obviously when a super stalker wants to
be your buddy that's never a good sign
and they're freaky friendship soon
escalates to a game of cat-and-mouse
with some very serious stakes while
we've seen similar stories before the
highlight here is the tension between
Graham and Hill both playing characters
we empathize with even though we
wouldn't necessarily want to hang out
with either of them Buster's mal Hart
thrillers don't come much stranger than
2016's Busters mal Hart written and
directed by Sarah Smith the movie finds
Rami Malek playing a bearded mountain
man on the run from the cops this outlaw
hobo is named Buster and when he's not
breaking into cabins he's ranting about
an upcoming apocalypse he calls the
inversion but how did Buster get to this
place with gun wielding cops on his
trail
well you'll start to find out as the
film jumps back to in Buster was a
family man named Jonah clean shaven and
suffocating Jonah is a hotel concierge
who feels trapped by the system until a
conspiracy theorist shows up with wild
ideas about y2k and robbing banks making
all this even stranger we occasionally
get glimpses of a third version of malok
lost at sea adding to the uneasy dream
vibe of the whole film busters mal Hart
has some twists that will keep you
guessing but ultimately it's a
mind-bending movie that will cause you
to praise Rami Malik's acting abilities
while questioning the nature of reality
itself the fury of a patient man set in
Madrid the fury of a patient man follows
a seemingly gentle man named Jose who
falls in love with a lonely woman named
Ana her husband Luis has been behind
bars for his part in a jewel heist and
of course we all know things are going
to get messy when he's finally released
but just when you think you know where
it's going the movie sets off in an
entirely different direction this brutal
2016 spanish-language film features some
brilliantly suspenseful scenes like a
tense moment in a boxing gym and one
shot car chase that ends in a terrific
wreck
bad day for the cut-set in Northern
Ireland 2007 teams bad day for the cut
is gory proof that you don't mess with
farmers and you especially don't mess
with farmers moms the film focuses on a
middle-aged man named Donal a farmer who
spent most of his life taking care of
his elderly mother but his quiet
existence is turned upside down when
she's killed after what seems to be a
home invasion gone wrong after joining
forces with another victim Donal sets
out to collect an eye-for-an-eye but he
quickly realizes there are quite a few
secrets in his family tree still that
doesn't stop him from taking on an army
of bad guys to take revenge against the
crime lord responsible for taking out
his mom if you're a fan of crime flicks
from the UK bad day for the cut will
definitely be a good time on Netflix
Icarus directed by Brian Fogle 2017
Icarus picked up the Oscar for Best
Documentary at the 90th Academy Awards
the film opens with folda wanting to
explore the world of
performance-enhancing drugs by injecting
himself with all kinds of chemicals
before competing in a bike race his
little stunt soon leads him to dr.
Gregory ROG Knopf a colorful character
in the man in charge of Russia's
anti-doping program soon ROG Knopf is
fearing for his life and we watch as he
maneuvers around KGB agents escapes the
country and faces the possibility of
assassination a documentary that will
have you on the edge of your seat Icarus
is a perfect mix of informative
storytelling and real-life thrills
shimmer Lake sort of like Fargo crossed
with memento shimmer Lake is a backwards
story of bumbling criminals who can't
stop screwing up taking a page from the
Christopher Nolan playbook this 2017
Netflix original starts at the end and
works its way toward the beginning as a
group of small-town crooks plan and
carry out a robbery yeah Chris it's
real good super good
without a doubt the highlight of the
film is Benjamin Walker a Zeke Sykes a
local sheriff who walked softly carries
a big stick and is forced to deal with
everything from idiot FBI agents to a
devious femme fatale Rainn Wilson is
also great a Zeke's brother Andy a
disgraced attorney who plays a key role
in the twisty plot if you've seen James
Gunn's super then you know Wilson has
impressive dramatic chops and he's
pretty great here as a despicable
desperate loser what am i banned in a
car forever a cornfield I spent the
night in the junkyard
and if the backwards time line sounds a
bit gimmicky don't worry it pays off
beautifully making shimmer like a dark
tail that's totally worth unraveling